Nothing can bring a movie audience to tears
like the death of a beloved character.
But when an actor or actress's on screen death
is well-deserved, insanely over the top, or
delivered at the hands of a horror icon, viewers
may be too busy laughing or cheering instead.
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Funniest Movie Deaths.
A Nightmare on Elm Street
Since Freddy Krueger uses dreams to take out
teenagers, every kill in the series is ridiculous
in some way.
But when Nancy's mother is surprised by the
slasher, he smashes an arm through a glass
window - and the viewer's suspension of disbelief.
It's obviously impossible to actually pull
the actress through the window, but the awkward
dummy taking her place turns the genuine jump
scare into a bad joke.
Live and Let Die
As crazy or hard to believe as some of James
Bond's kills have been, there's no debating
the weirdest.
When 007 has his showdown with the villain
of Live and Let Die, a short, awkward grapple
sends both men into a shark tank, where James
leaves his opponent to die.
Not by shark, but one of the villain's own
Inflating bullets.
When the man floated to the ceiling and exploded,
the audience wasn't laughing at the twist
- they were laughing at how ridiculous Roger
Moore's super spy had really become.
Deep Blue Sea
When a movie is absolutely filled with ridiculous
deaths, it takes something special for one
kill to rise above the rest.
Or in this case, just a passionate speech
from Samuel L. Jackson.
When his character has shown why he's just
the man to help the movies cast survive an
assault from super-smart sharks, the fish
get the last laugh, cutting his plan short
with a single bite.
The surprise and absurdity of the kill made
it one of Hollywood's cult favourites, eventually
becoming well known even if movie fans never
sat through the entire shark drama.
Zombieland
Audiences were shocked enough when comedy
icon Bill Murray made a surprise appearance
as himself in this post-apocalyptic tale.
Ever the kidder, Murray's decision to scare
another survivor winds up costing him, but
his sudden and unceremonious death is the
perfect exit.
Letting him dish out some deadpan humor, and
even a playful shot at his worst-reviewed
role to date, the actor made sure his cameo
would be remembered as one of the movie's
best moments.
And with his dying breath, showed there's
always time for another joke.
Big Trouble in Little China
No list of insane movie deaths is complete
without this entry from the classic Kurt Russel
martial arts fantasy.
When his trucker hero has managed to take
out the supernatural villain of Big Trouble,
the warlord's lieutenant is more than a little
angry.
Instead of looking for revenge, he lets his
anger build, eventually inflating him to a
level of ridiculousness that the movie had
yet to reach, before exploding in a burst
of lettuce.
The death alone is worth the movies entire
runtime.
Zoolander
Ben Stiller made an entire movie out of the
idea that fashion supermodels aren't exactly
gifted thinkers, but the true stupidity of
Derek Zoolander's best friends only became
clear moments before their death.
Food fights, pillow fights, and snowball fights
are all in good fun, but a gasoline fight
is asking for trouble.
The gag might have been one of biggest reaches
in the entire movie, but there's no denying
its staying power.
There are lots of laughs to be had throughout
the movie, but the scene - and it's fiery
end - are impossible to forget.
Total Recall
It's hard to tell what's true and what isn't
in this sci-fi classic, but when Arnold Schwarzenegger
finally gets to Mars, he sends the movie's
villain out onto the planet's surface.
Without any air to breathe, he's dead in under
a minute.
Well, the oozing, swelling plastic version
if him is, anyway.
If the movie really is all in Quaid's head,
then he never learned what a lack of oxygen
would do to a human being.
But he's clearly a fan of schlocky horror.
MacGruber
It's hard to pick just one memorable death
in this SNL feature film, since the final
act sends the hero into a throat-ripping frenzy.
But MacGruber finally gets the payback he's
been waiting for when his nemesis shows up
to ruin his wedding.
It wasn't enough to beat Dieter Von Kunth
and throw him to his death.
The handy hero needed to riddle him with bullets
on the way down, and even run salt in the
wound by desecrating his corpse.....
Twice.
The guy can really hold a grudge.
True Lies
Director James Cameron set a record with the
budget of his action-comedy True Lies, but
audiences got to enjoy every dollar of it
on the big screen.
As star Arnold Schwarzenegger battles a group
of terrorists out of a skyscraper and onto
the wings of a fighter jet, audiences probably
thought things had gotten as insane as possible.
But with the villain hanging from one of the
fighter's missiles, and his partners escaping
in a nearby helicopter, Arnold decides to
solve two problems at once.
Delivering one of the most laughable kills
in his entire career.
Team America: World Police
The actors may not be humans, but that only
guaranteed that each and every single kill
and stunt in Team America would be a surefire
gag.
The squad's celebration is cut short when
one surviving terrorist suddenly cuts down
one of their own.
Even though the twist has been seen in dozens
of action flicks, the tragedy of a puppet
being cut down in his prime, and the insane
death dance of his killer is impossible not
to laugh at.
Those are just a few of our favorite funny
movie deaths, but did we miss any of your
favorite outrageous kills?
Be sure to leave them in the comments, and
subscribe to our channel for more videos like
this one.